i've always
been interested in working on systems
when i'm talking about systems what i
mean is that often
we talk about issues as sort of siloed
things
climate's over here poverty is over here
access to higher education is over here
but the fact is
that all of those problems they all
exist sort of like within
the same system and a lot of times
those systems intersect every time
you change a policy you are changing a
system every time rihanna gun wright
wants to tell you that the world is more
connected
than you might think she's the director
of climate policy at the roosevelt
institute
and one of the architects of the green
new deal the sweeping comprehensive
climate legislation
championed by alexandria ocasio-cortez
and met by political opponents with
let's say some criticism after reading
the green new deal
i'm mostly afraid of not being able to
get through this speech
with a straight face the green new deal
is expansive it's comprehensive
so how does a woman with fewer than
three years of experience in the world
of climate justice
end up writing one of the most
controversial and impactful climate
bills in american history
because she saw that everything in
american power is connected
and she wants everyone else to see it
with her
[Music]
born and raised in chicago rihanna gun
wright grew up with asthma
and i had asthma to the point that by
the time i think i was in like
third or fourth grade i was out for like
a week every spring
i would get sick and i would be out of
school
she didn't make the connection at the
time but we now know today that her
asthma
like many others was most likely linked
to the air pollution in her neighborhood
where she grew up
the situation for a lot of other kids
was that their parents worked hourly
jobs right
so every time your child is out of
school not only are you hurting their
educational outcomes
you have mothers trying to figure out
what to do about child care
these things are all connected
that connection has not only shaped gun
rights world view
but the fundamental tenets of the green
new deal
a lot of what the green new deal did was
just
connect a lot of conversations that were
happening already
climate justice and environmental
justice activists have been talking
about how
environment is larger than polar bears
and ice caps in the arctic
so it was just essentially trying to
create a policy proposal that not just
met the scale of the problem but
actually tried to address the problem
as it exists in the real world which is
a mass of overlapping
and interconnected issues the green new
deal is a 14-page document and it covers
a lot of ground it not only promises to
get carbon emissions to net zero by 2050
but to add millions of green jobs and
makes the link that climate issues like
fossil fuel emissions
are justice issues since people of color
are more likely to live near power
plants and other polluting factories
and they suffer higher levels of asthma
and greater risk of early death
from air pollution
while rihanna's writing of the green new
deal may be one of the most influential
documents in the green space
she's a relative newcomer when it comes
to climate justice
for her she sees that as an asset
instead of a hindrance
when we talk about climate change most
times people are talking about super
scientific stuff
carbon footprints parts per million how
much carbon is in the atmosphere
and there's this feeling i feel like
often in climate policy that you if you
don't have a background on those things
you can't talk about
it but the fact is that most people
experience
climate change as economic effects and
health effects
they experience it as hurricane katrina
they experience it as the wildfires
in paradise they experience it as this
heat wave where they don't have money to
afford air conditioning
climate change is not a partisan thing
so rihanna took this pragmatic approach
all throughout her career originally she
was a policy analyst for the detroit
health department
and detroit is a hotbed for
environmental injustice
when i was working there there was an
incinerator in the middle of the city
and around that area asthma rates were
like three times
the state average residents were
complaining that they couldn't go
outside because it smelled so bad
so trying to figure out what to do about
it it just became clear that these
things had
health effects but the reasons that it
was happening were beyond what we could
do for people
so after working on abdul syed's 2018
michigan gubernatorial campaign and
losing
rihanna was looking for a job so she
emailed congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez's campaign manager
looking for something short-term and
when she was offered a job at new
consensus a progressive think
tank they're like hey so we are
developing a green new deal
which is a mobilization on climate to
restructure the us economy and reduce
emissions
in addition the idea was to create the
lofty goal
of zero waste zero poverty and zero
racial wealth gap so they were like oh
so
you can write this whole thing in like
four months right
and i was like no but maybe if you give
me two research assistants
we can try uh and so
that's what we did
no one does economic mobilizations
anymore in the u.s the last time we did
that was in world war
ii so the first thing we had to figure
out was like
how do you actually run an industrial
mobilization
what does that look like that's when
rihanna brought in
other organizations to not only pitch
ideas for what the green new deal should
look like
but how to shift power structures and
figure out how money should be dispersed
so i work with a green new deal network
which is essentially
a coalition of movements but
what became clear was the folks who had
been put together
were not climate justice organizers or
advocates
that's john washington he's part of the
green new deal network
and he's worked with rihanna during his
time at people united for sustainable
housing
or push initially he had
doubts about rihanna's new deal
coalition they were folks who had had
success like rihanna in electoral work
but who had never done climate justice
work and so
rihanna recognized that there was a gap
in that and really took
it all in and built a relationship with
myself and
many others across the climate justice
movement
the only way we're going to figure out
how to do such big
intersectional policy is to have people
from various
not only viewpoints and expertise but
people
that are going to be affected by this in
the room talking to each other building
relationships and working together
one of those people she listened to is
lucy velez she lives in buffalo
and she's a climate justice activist
while her story is only tangentially
related to an environmental issue
it's actually addressing the knock-on
effects that spill over
into different but connected areas of
life
i thought you know my cough was just a
cough all these
uh congestion issues and colds were just
things that
normally you know most people experience
like rihanna lucy suffered from
persistent medical issues from pollution
most likely caused by the peace bridge
connecting buffalo to canada
which emitted emissions into the
surrounding neighborhoods
in the year 98 i got a house and
i thought that that house was in good
condition
but in 2016 i was
hospitalized with like a lung and brown
kill infection
and when lucy returned from the hospital
i went into a room
which happened to be my office and there
was this black
fuzzy mold
that's when members of push knocked on
lucy's door one day
and they were able to help her fix her
house it took a while to find different
funding sources to add up to the amount
of money it was required to fix lucy's
home
because it was in pretty bad shape the
cost to my house
was forty thousand dollars to cover
the things that i needed so lucy got her
home fixed
and then a few months later she gets a
thing from keybank saying that they're
redoing her mortgage
because the value of her home has gone
up her mortgage payment was doubled
i didn't have the money i couldn't find
the money to pay for
you know that kind of that kind of jump
and so she used part of her burial fund
to pay her taxes so she could keep her
house
that's the problem with lucy's situation
it started as a pollution related issue
and that issue ended up affecting her
mortgage
that domino effect is what the green new
deal is trying to address
that's what einstein said right the
consciousness that created a problem is
not the consciousness that's going to
solve it
so the consciousness of the non-profit
and private world is not what's going to
solve the problem it's the consciousness
of the community
and so i think the green new deal
network and the team have started really
to
to to address that they've started to
build a national network of
organizations that do this work
and that understand what people in
communities are experiencing
[Music]
today's biggest issue with
interconnected consequences
for a fourth straight day the
coronavirus claimed more than 1 000
lives in this country
infections are also still surging but
with covid spreading throughout the
united states
it seems that climate issues including
the green new deal
are taking a back seat to the pandemic
but that hasn't stopped opponents
making their feelings known what does
placing emissions standards on
airlines have to do with getting iowa
families and workers
the relief they need right now we're
here trying to fight for the man and
woman on the street in our hometowns
and yet they're fighting for the green
new deal
but rihanna says that covid and climate
justice have one major thing in common
they both ravage poor communities of
color and it's not a coincidence
if you look at the hot spots of covet
deaths
they basically mapped on almost directly
onto front line communities
one of the reasons why covet ravaged
communities of color was because we put
toxic pollution there and now
covet is taking them out at double the
[Applause]
rates
with joe biden's 1.7 trillion dollar
green initiative plan
some are calling it his own spin on the
green new deal
so it's catching on in the mainstream
but rihanna still knows she has a long
hard fight ahead of her
because ultimately changing an entire
system
means getting citizens to realize their
own power
over that system we ran into a lot of
people who would talk about
how they felt powerless
[Music]
but they always had power in some
measure
and it's just really important to
remember
that you have the right to gather with
other people
[Music]
we all have the ability to emotionally
affect another person to make another
person feel connected
and that is powerful
[Music]